pensemos en cuánto estrés dividido entre
un cuarto pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo les daré una pista tomen tres
enteros y dividirlo en secciones que
sean de un cuarto de entero cada una y
luego piense en cuántas secciones tienen
muy bien vamos a trabajar en esto juntos
déjenme dibujar tres enteros aquí
tenemos un entero este es otro entero y
este es mi tercer entero los voy a
dividir en piezas o secciones que sean
iguales a un cuarto de un entero así que
dividió este entero en cuatro piezas que
son de un cuarto cada una un cuarto de
cuatro cuartos luego aquí tengo otros
cuatro cuartos y aquí tengo otros cuatro
cuartos otra forma de pensar en esto es
que dividir mis tres enteros en cuartos
si los divido en cuartos cuántas piezas
voy a tener bueno esto es muy sencillo
tenemos una dos tres
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 piezas y no tenía
que contarlas cada entero tiene cuatro
cuartos entonces tres enteros es igual a
tres por cuatro que es igual a 12 piezas
o dos secciones así que esto es igual a
12 otra forma de pensar en esto es que
si tenemos 3 enteros y los dividimos en
secciones iguales a un cuarto vamos a
tener dos secciones iguales terminamos